after that first touchdown um your
teammates were trying to give you the
the ball uh why why wouldn't you take it
because i mean that doesn't really
matter it was you know one touchdown we
gotta score more
but
it's not like the game was over right
there but i mean
we got to do better in the red zone and
get more touchdowns and we will
welcome to the new england media mac
jones dealing with the hard-pressed
questions after the game what did you
think of his performance i i liked it i
mean first off he's already like bought
into the bill belichick media press
conference like he's not gonna give you
anything that's for sure but i think
what we saw in the preseason is again
what we saw from mac jones a guy that's
pretty polished understands the big
picture of the game and then just makes
a lot of the appropriate throws and
moves in the pocket this was not easy
today the dolphins defense made a lot of
good quarterbacks look like fools last
year they got good corners pretty good
up front and like i said they had
knowledge of the scheme altogether
because all the coaches down in miami
are from new england but i thought all
in all it was a really good start and of
course he gave them a chance to win the
football game so many eyes on these
rookie quarterbacks coming out of the
preseason coming into today's action
let's talk about zach wilson cause you
highlighted him a little bit in what you
said after the highlights from that game
with the jets but big picture reason for
hope here for the new york jets i think
so i think the like goal number one is
to be like don't joe burrow zach wilson
which you just put too much of the game
on his shoulders week after week after
week so then he gets hurt and hurts your
franchise for years and years so you
know yes if i'm a jets fan it wasn't
pretty today but i think the thing you
could take away is going man we fought
we kind of hung in there and our
quarterback even after taking a beating
he kind of bounced back and made some
again jaw-dropping throws that we saw
throughout the preseason that to me
impressed me mac jones probably played
the cleanest game out of the rookies
zach wilson still made the most
eye-popping plays out of the rookies
it's just going to be tough for sledding
for him with the jets team as compared
to mack jones in new england all right
as for we heard you guys talk earlier in
the show justin fields getting a little
glimpse uh there in chicago and that
bears lost to the rims let's hear what
he had to say afterwards
i mean it felt great you know finally
getting out there uh getting some i
guess real nfl action uh with with uh
the starters and stuff like that but um
it wasn't weird at me running in and out
just because you know this past we were
practicing
um that some of that stuff so i was used
to it
how do you stay engaged on the sideline
when you're not in
i'm sorry how do you stay engaged on the
sideline when you're not uh yeah so
earlier in the game i was pretty much
acting like i was in the game so when
coach would say to play through the mic
i would just repeat it to myself and
kind of act like i was saying it in the
huddle and that's pretty much how i was
staying engaged and just making sure my
legs were warmed up in case you know you
caught my package out there so
just on the touchdown room what's the
the key point there for you of knowing
when to cut it up and what did you see
specifically on that um you know it's
that's just a regular eat option so uh
basically reading the end he froze a
little bit and i thought i could beat
him around the edge so i just tried to
uh just get the ball in zone so pretty
simple play what was your expectation
for the amount of snaps you might get in
this game did it play out sort of how
you thought or did the game flop changed
uh i came in the game not expecting a
certain amount of snaps i was just ready
to play whenever coach called my name so
i wasn't expecting a certain amount of
snaps at all
that first throw matt was science was an
rpo what did you kind of see there yeah
i just saw free access uh in the
boundary with uh jaylen on marquis so i
just took that a little uh five year
speed up
what do you gain out of five snaps in
the first game how you feel about the
atmosphere you know see how fast those
guys are coming you know kind of see uh
i guess
it's it's different behind the o-line
and you know just the the d-line and
stuff like that so it's different when
you're actually on the field rather than
being on the sidelines so you just kind
of get that experience in there and you
know just just being out there just kind
of getting used to the speed and stuff
so yeah seems to be a significant surge
in energy when you score can you tell us
what it felt like in that that end zone
with your teammates coming over and kind
of put them on yeah it was awesome uh of
course first career touchdown and you
know i just wanted to celebrate with
them and of course you know cole and
those guys were excited we were just
talking about that in the locker room uh
he almost ran me over but you know i
mean we were all excited for sure and um
i just celebrated with my teammate so
did i kick the ball did you keep the
ball oh yeah yeah i'm definitely gonna
keep doing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports